Well, hey, a couple weeks ago, we started a brand new series here at the porch in the book of Genesis.
It just felt fitting, you know, beginning of the year, beginning of the Bible.
They just seem to be a match made in heaven, no pun intended.
And so we've been journeying Genesis 1, Genesis 2.
We had a conversation kind of in the middle there, whenever the snowstorm hit.
And tonight, we are sitting in, what is one of the most iconic passages of scripture we are looking at Genesis 3?
So if you have a Bible, you can go ahead and turn there with me.
Right now, while you're doing that, I'll just lead off with a story, because I think
Maybe my misery can set us up pretty well.
Here's what happened a couple of weeks ago.
Brooke and I, we had just finished dinner.
And we were playing with cash right before bedtime.
We were sitting in our sunroom.
And so we're kind of closing the evening down.
And so I get up and I go to the kitchen.
I know there's some dishes.
And so I start to make my way just to do some dishes before we go and we put the little baby boy to sleep.
And as I'm walking into the kitchen, I step into a puddle of water.
And it just occurred to me.
Maybe it's a leak off of the fridge.
Sometimes you get tap water and things spill.
Maybe it's something off the dishwasher, pulling out plates or dishes and finding that stuff kind of leaves a mess.
Maybe it was Cassius water cup.
He has a tendency to just kind of throw that thing around and leave a mess wherever it falls.
And so I step back to survey the damage of what am I really dealing with here?
And as I take it all in, what I realize to my horror is it's way worse than I thought it was.
Because it was not just a puddle of water.
It was a pool of water streaming into our entryway from the
where our guest bathroom is.
And so I pull back the pocket door and I put on my slides and I begin to make my way into what is a damage zone.
I mean, it is an absolute mess in here.
And so I know my way around some things in the house.
I'm kind of a DIY sort of guy.
And yet one of the things that I do not claim to have any kind of fame with is plumbing.
I know next to nothing about plumbing, but, and fellas if you don't know this,
You need to learn it.
You know to turn off the water behind the toilet should ever the toilet be overflowing.
So I swiftly move and I grab the knob and I spin it righty-tidy which shuts down the water.
And then I grab a pitcher and I start to drain it off into the sink.
As I'm doing that, as I'm
repairing what appears to be a broken situation, the situation only seems to break all the more because as I'm draining the water off into the sink, the toilet continues to overflow and I have no idea what's happening because in this moment I've already shut off the water.
And yet, the water's spilling, I'm erasing and so I go and I grab not one but two pictures, I'm double fisting trying to get the water out of the toilet into the sink to keep my house from becoming an absolute blood zone.
And yet, a moment comes where I realize I'm out of my depth, and so I do what no self-respecting husband does.
I look at my wife and I ask her to call her father.
And as she calls my father-in-law, and she's explaining to him what's happening in this moment, that I'm draining the water out, that the toilets continuing to overflow, that I'm racing around, and she just says to him, hey, we don't know what's wrong, and I hear my father-in-law.
laugh on the other end of the line.
He goes, you're what's wrong.
Because little did I know that we had a clog in the main kitchen clean out, which just means that all the water I was taking from the toilet and putting in the sink was just coming back up the toilet.
So where I thought I was actually helping the situation, I was only hurting the situation.
Now, why do I tell you that?
the world has been asking that same question.
What's gone wrong for centuries?
And while they're not asking that question to deduce the problems of their bathroom, they are asking that question because they look at the landscape of life around and they realize something is wrong, things are not as they should be.
You can look
No matter who it is you speak to, whoever it is you reference, you can go back into the history books and you can see how people have tried to explain the origins of evil.
You can look at Plato and Augustine.
You can say that they would say evil wasn't an alternative good.
It was a privation of good.
It was the absence of good.
You can go to Eastern religions like Hinduism and Buddhism and what you can learn is that evil isn't necessarily a rebellion against God as much as it's a confusion about the way
the world works, you can go away from those Eastern religions and you can actually turn to dualism, which may be confusing to you, but it's actually a system of belief that many in our world that do not claim faith would ascribe to, that there's not just good, but there's bad, they are equal opposing forces, it's the idea of yin and yang, there's a light side and there's a dark side, there's two dogs and they're trying to get the better of one another, you can go and you can ask an evolutionist, hey, what is the origin of evil and what they would say is, oh, it's the result of survival instinct, you know, in order for someone to win, someone's gotta lose,
If you wanted to go and you wanted to reference psychology, what you would see is that evil is the byproduct of negative circumstances that results in a negative emotional condition.
It's where fear and insecurity and trauma come out of.
That's what everything in the past would say.
But if you wanted to zoom all the way here to the present and ask our current cultural moment, hey, what is it?
that explains why things are the way they are.
What in fact has gone wrong?
You would see people present a variety of answers.
It might be global warming or the industrial military complex and a lack of gun control.
You might see that people would say it's political outrage, it's poor policy making.
It's people divided over issues that ultimately do not matter at the cost of one another.
You would see that it would be something in lines of an ever-evolving sexual revolution.
It could be economic strain, rising,
Cost of living, anybody say amen to that one?
And if that's not enough, if the past and if the present isn't enough, you could make your way over to LA, you could look at Hollywood, you could see what they have to say because we have a thing for prequels all of a sudden, most of which are not very good.
But we have this fascination to understand what's gone wrong.
There's a reason that we need to not just live with episodes four, five, and six, but we got to go back to Star Wars episodes one, two, and three, so that way we can understand why Vader's voice sounds the way it does.
There's a reason why the rings of power came out because people have questions about where Sauron came from.
If you wanted to go even further, you could look at Wicked, one of the rare good ones.
And what you can see is an explanation for why we have that Wicked Witch of the West.
Everyone's asking what's gone wrong.
You want to know what's gone wrong?
We did.
We went wrong.
That's what the Bible tells us from page 3.
In Genesis chapter 3, what we find is, yes, one of the most iconic Bible stories ever written.
It is a story that
not only Christians, but many non-Christians know because the story of Adam and Eve and the snake transcends time.
It's one that resonates deeply with people because it provides an explanation for that question which we can find no good answer to.
And yet here's the danger of this story.
because it is so iconic, we have a tendency to approach it and bring all of our preconceptions with us.
We walk into it and we don't take God on his terms.
We take the story on someone else's terms.
We don't listen to what he says.
We recall what someone else has said in the past.
I'm not telling you to just eject everything you've learned in the past.
What I am saying is in this moment, it would serve you really well to read this story with fresh eyes alongside me.
Does that sound good?
I want you to,
Look at this text and understand what it's actually saying, because we often misunderstand its meaning.
And so we're just going to walk through it top to bottom.
And I'm just going to explain to you what's happening.
If you want to know what's gone wrong, and if you want to know, why do we go wrong?
This is going to tell you.
Verse one.
Now the serpent
was more crafty than any other beast of the field that the Lord God had made.
He said to the woman, did God actually say, you shall not eat of any tree in the garden?
And the woman said to the serpent, we may eat of the fruit of the trees in the garden, but God said you shall not eat of the fruit of the tree that is in the midst of the garden.
Neither shall you touch it.
Why lest you die?
The first thing you need to know is things go wrong when we forget God's word.
Things go wrong when we forget God's word.
Like right out of the gate.
Once we start reading through this story, there's a few things that pop up and should appear odd to us, should seem strange.
Some signal players should be firing off into the atmosphere of your intellect.
And the reason why is because we see, not just the woman, but we see the snake, both misrepresent what God has said in the stories that we've already read through Genesis 1 and Genesis 2.
They do not correctly identify his commands, which begs the question then, what were God's commands?
Well, Genesis 2, 16, 17 tells you, it's kind of a two-part command.
The first command that God gave is, hey, you can eat of every tree in the garden, which is an amazing command.
Because what it tells us is that God has looked upon Adam and Eve and he has said, hey, everything
In the garden, it's fair game.
Like you can get out there and you can take your pick.
You can literally, you can enter into the proverbial grocery store and you can pick whatever you want off the shelves and it is not gonna actually add to your waistline.
It's only going to lead to your joy.
There's nothing here that you have to earn.
Everything here is freely given.
How amazing is that?
Then there's the second part.
The second part of the command is but,
Just don't eat of one tree.
Don't eat of the tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
Why God?
Because then you'll die.
It's funny.
We read that command and what we often hear is God say, but do not eat of the tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
Or I'll kill you.
That's not what actually is said here.
What's said here is you'll die.
God is not coming to us and saying, hey, you need to perform for my approval.
That's not what he's saying.
He's saying, no, joy is fully available to you.
This is not about being performative.
This is about being preventative.
God is saying, hey, there is a whole world for you to enjoy all of this goodness that I have blessed you with.
And yet there's one thing that will mess it up.
So just don't do that.
God's first command, it's not a prohibition to your joy.
It's an invitation to joy.
That's what God is inviting Adam and Eve into from the very beginning of the story.
And yet, look at the way that the snake twists God's command.
He says, did God actually say, you shall not eat of any tree in the garden?
It's interesting.
This is the way the enemy works.
He doesn't need you to start by just denying God.
He needs you to start by just doubting him.
He just wants you to see that there might be something else available on the table.
He doesn't need you to just reject God.
That'd be a really hard sell.
But because he's crafty, what he does is he looks and he says, no, you don't have to reject God, but I do want you to accept sin.
He doesn't approach Eve with a smoking vial of poison, take and drink.
You know, that's not what he does.
He comes to her with what?
Something that is delightful, that is pleasing to the eye.
He comes in
And he presents an option that appears satisfying.
And what we see is that as she accepts sin, she takes the first step in forgetting God.
Because we can just read her words and we can see that that's true.
What are her words?
Her words are, you shall not eat of the tree in the midst or in the middle of the garden.
That's what she responds to the snake with, which is incorrect.
Why?
Because the tree of the knowledge of good and evil, according to God's estimation, is not in the middle of the garden.
God has said that the tree of life is in the middle of the garden.
The tree of the knowledge of good and evil is nearby, but God distinctly identifies the tree of life as the middle of his garden.
But for Eve, the tree of the knowledge of good and evil is the center of her garden.
It's the middle of her
affection.
It is the orbit around all of her attention.
Why is that?
Well, it tells us something really important about human nature.
We are so very quick to forget all that God has given.
And we are so very quick to focus on all that he hasn't.
Don't we do this?
Don't we focus on what we don't have as opposed to what we do have?
Got a great job, but I don't have a boyfriend or a girlfriend.
Man, I got an amazing personality, but I hate my body.
Man, I've got people that love me, support me, or cheer inform me, but they're not the right kind of people.
I want to be with those people instead.
Do you see how this works?
Figure it out for yourself.
We all do this.
We all look at what we have and we identify it as insufficient.
We want something else.
We want something more.
And I think, and that's important, I think this.
I don't actually see this clearly from the text because it doesn't tell us explicitly, but I do think.
that what we get an eye into from this specific moment as Eve has centered her attention on the tree of the knowledge of good and evil as being in the middle of her garden, what we see is a heart of ingratitude springing up, which is the root, the first step to all sin.
It's an ungrateful heart, which begs the question, where in your heart are you ungrateful for what God has given?
The second thing that we see her say, which helps us to understand that
Man, she is actually forgetting God's word, and she says, neither shall you touch it.
Which isn't just a misunderstanding of what God has said.
It's actually not even included in God's command.
God never said that.
It's an addition that she adds on to what God has said.
It's interesting, when you read through the Bible, the Pharisees, which were the religious leaders of Jesus' day, those guys who were most biblically informed, they were the ones that were notoriously bad at this.
They were horrible about adding things on to God's word.
They actually rabbinnically had these things known as fence laws.
Fence laws, there were hundreds, if not thousands, of these laws that served to protect them from going too far, disobeying God's word.
And yet for fear going too far, you know what they did?
They never went far enough.
Too often, this happens to Christians, particularly good Christians.
We find ourselves for fear of going too far,
going far enough, we become a legalistic.
We start thinking about what we do and what we don't do as opposed to what God has done.
And as a result, you know what it does?
It evokes within the spirit of a person this deep fear of losing this life that I have as opposed to enjoying the life that God has come to give.
These are Eve's two mistakes.
She has fallen prey to a very dangerous trap.
You want to know what the trap is?
The trap is she knows
just enough about God, which is something we so very often fall into ourselves.
Like, we know enough about God to believe in Him, to claim the identity of Christian, but we don't know enough about Jesus to know what we actually believe, to actually articulate the gospel.
We know enough about God to love Him, but we don't know enough about God
to give all of our life to Him, to surrender our every affection, to make sure that there's no part of us that's divided in any other place but is totally united in loving Him and Him alone.
We know enough about God to trust Him, but we don't know enough about God to surrender every single inch of our life.
There are things we hold back, pieces of ourselves we don't want him to touch, because though we say we do, we don't actually trust him.
We know just enough about God to be dangerous at this whole Christian thing, but we don't know enough about God to keep ourselves from being in danger to ourselves.
Psalm 119, verse nine, it says this, how can a young man or woman keep their way pure by guarding it
according to what, to your word?
With my whole heart, I seek you.
Let me not wander from your commandments.
I've stored up your word in my heart that I might not sin against you.
Do you hear it?
That kind of ferocious faith that depends wholeheartedly on the words of God?
So let me ask you something, because I think that this is a helpful litmus test.
Whenever your life goes sideways, whenever things just kind of fall off the normal path and things become very, very difficult, what comes out of you?
Like whenever you get fired unexpectedly, what's your natural response?
Whenever that guy whom you've been dating for years at this point breaks up with you instead of going into marriage with you, what comes out of you?
Whenever you find some loved one, a family member, a dear friend comes down with some sort of fatal diagnosis, what comes out of you?
Jesus faced.
The three most pressure-packed moments in his story.
Tempted in the wilderness before he began his ministry, Garden of Gethsemane, the night of his arrest, and Calvary dying for the sins of the world.
And you want to know what came out of him?
The words of God.
Virtually every single word he spoke
in those moments that were most pressure packed.
They were God's words.
Why?
Not because he's just trying to fulfill prophecy.
He does that.
That's true.
He does fulfill prophecy in the process.
of saying these things amidst these difficulties.
But that's not why he does it.
He does it.
He speaks these things.
Because out of the overflow of the heart, guess what?
The mouth is gonna speak.
He speaks out what he has engraved on his mind.
God has etched into his heart the very person that he has become as he has walked with God.
That person is particularly exposed in those moments of greatest difficulty.
You see, Jesus knew.
things go wrong when we forget God's word, but things go right when we remember it.
That's the first one.
Look at verse four, but the serpent, she said, the serpent said to the woman, you will not surely die for God knows that when you eat of it, your eyes will be opened and you'll be like God knowing good and evil.
So the second thing you got to know is that things go wrong when we question God's character.
Things go wrong when we question God's character.
It's a really subtle detail mentioned in here, but we talked last week about how over the course of chapter two and chapter three, which is actually the narrative that we're a part of in this moment.
One is the creation story from like 50,000 feet.
It's up at God's level.
It's seeing everything come to be all at once.
And yet when you get to Genesis two, it's again a different vantage point.
Like if you were watching instant replay on the Super Bowl, you might get one angle to show one side and then a different angle to show a different side.
Genesis two is a different angle to the same story.
And what we see as we zoom specifically in on humanity is that story continues into chapter three.
As we move into chapter three, we see a pattern that was established last week.
That pattern is that Moses who authored this book talks about God in a twofold title.
He calls him Lord God 20 times, like on repeat.
Like he hit that button mistakenly on Spotify and the song just keeps playing over and over and over and over again.
That's what's happening right here.
He calls him Lord God or Elohim Yahweh.
It's a two-fold title.
It's a bundle deal.
And yet though that happens 20 times as the particular title of God, you know what pops up in this story?
A different title.
And that title is not Elohim Yahweh.
It's Elohim.
And guess who calls him that?
The serpent.
The serpent takes Lord God and throws out the Lord and just calls him God because what he's trying to do is he is trying to impersonalize the character of God to Eve.
He wants her to know, hey, that caring and covenantal nature, all that is good and represented in the personal, intimate identity of God through Yahweh, don't pay attention to that.
just focus instead on the fact that he's transcendent.
He's all powerful.
He's distant and he's disinterested.
Sure, he's in control of things, but he doesn't really care what's happening in your life.
He's not really holding you to the things that he said.
He's far off and not paying attention right now.
He is all powerful, but he's not all personal.
Don't worry about that.
Why does he do it?
Because he wants to render God
as an impersonal God.
I remember years ago, applied for this job, was really excited for the opportunity.
It was a great organization.
I knew some of the people that worked there was thinking this was going to be a great next step.
And yet, though I knew some people, I got rejected, not by the way of a phone call.
I got rejected by the way of an email.
Anybody been there?
And what happens in that moment is it feels cold and it feels calculated.
And though we had relationship
Some distrust came out of me.
I started to feel a kind of way about these people.
Why?
Because it lacked a personal touch.
The serpent, he wants Eve and Satan.
He wants you to forget the personal touch of God.
He wants you to question his character.
And yet what we know is God's question or God's character is not in question.
And the reason we know it is because there's a couple of reasons specifically in these two verses.
The first is found in that false promise that the serpent gives Eve.
He says, once you eat of it, you'll be like God.
Here's the sad irony of that false promise.
She's already like God.
That was declared by God.
in the last two chapters.
He looked at her and he said in Genesis 1, 26, let us make man an hour image after hour lightness, male and female, he created them.
Like Eve has failed to remember that a God-given identity is not something you achieve, it is something you receive.
It is something that you cannot do anything to earn, you cannot say anything to earn, you cannot think anything to earn, no place you can go to actually earn it instead.
It's everything that God has done instead.
You see,
This is so tragic.
In Adam and Eve's effort to become like God, they become less like God.
They become more like the serpent.
They decide for themselves what is good, what is not good.
They choose their own way and in the process of doing so.
They become sinful.
The second reason we know that God's character is not in question here is because though Adam and Eve wanted to know
the knowledge of good and evil.
There's no implication here that God never intended to teach them that.
Actually, according to ancient tradition, there's a widely held belief that God did want to teach them the knowledge of good and evil, what the scripture also articulates as wisdom.
And we know it's true that God does want to teach us wisdom because James 1 tells us in verses 5 and 6, if any of you lacks wisdom, guess what?
Just ask God.
He gives it generously to all without reproach, and it will be given him, but let him
Ask in faith with no doubting.
For the one who doubts is like a wave of the sea that is driven and tossed by the wind.
You see, God gives wisdom to those that do not doubt, that don't question his character.
So let me ask you, because I think this is gonna hit home.
Why then do we question God's character?
Why do we seek wisdom on our own?
No man, he gives it freely.
Because he often does not give us
wisdom nearly as quick as we want it.
That's what happens to them.
They don't want it later.
They want it now.
And some of you, you can relate to that because you're dealing with the thought that man, the things that you want from God, they're taking too long for them to actually be loving.
Getting over the loss of a loved one, moving on from the betrayal of a friend, dealing with the difficulty of being single,
I don't know what it is for you, but whatever it is for you, what you need to realize is that often the fastest route to your happiness is not the wisest route.
God might have you in a season of suffering because he wants to walk with you through that season and help you learn not just who you are, but who he is.
That's what we see in Romans five.
He says, not only that, but we rejoice in what in our sufferings.
We rejoice in our sufferings.
What a crazy idea.
Knowing that suffering, it actually produces endurance and endurance.
It produces character and character.
It produces hope and hope.
It doesn't put us to shame because God's love has been poured into our hearts through the Holy Spirit who has been given to us.
That's why we trust God.
We trust God because He has poured His love into our hearts.
And yet the knowledge of that love, it does not come without suffering.
It comes through suffering.
It's fascinating to me recently.
I was watching this reel on YouTube and it was doing it before and after on drill sergeants.
And they would start talking and it's like, hey guys, like my name's whoever and I'm really excited, thankful to serve my country.
And then in the after it was like, my name is whatever.
I've yelled a lot over the last several years, and so my vocal cords are completely straight.
It was just like they were completely different people.
It's a beg the question, like, why are these guys so hardcore?
Like, why is it that over the course of these boot camps, they just feel the need to yell at all of these people, and the reason why is they know conflict reveals character.
You go through buds, it's hard.
You go through pair of rescue, it's hard.
You go through ranger camp, it's hard, because they want to see what people are made of.
Here's the amazing thing.
We know what God is made of.
We know his character because he suffered.
We witnessed by way of the word Christ endure on the cross all of the indulgence of our darkness.
We saw when we gave up on God, he did not give up on us.
Whenever we indulge darkness, he endured our darkness by way of death.
We have seen that he is who he says he is.
He is done what he said he would do.
He is good.
Things go wrong when we question God's character, but things they go right when we trust it.
Thirdly, look at verse six with me.
So when the woman saw that the tree was good for food, that it was a delight to the eyes, that the tree was to be desired to make one wise.
She took of its fruit and she ate and she also gave some of it to her husband who was with her and he ate.
Then the eyes of both, they were opened and they knew that they were naked.
And they sewed fig leaves together and they made themselves loincloths.
The third thing you need to know is things go wrong when we justify sin.
Things go wrong when we justify sin.
It's interesting.
It says that their eyes were opened.
The servant was actually consistent in that promise because their eyes were in fact opened.
And as their eyes were opened, they realized, we're naked, which is kind of a weird detail.
if you read over the course of chapters two and three, because it says that they're naked for different times.
That word naked, it should stand out as a peculiar piece to the rest of the story.
Again, if we're reading it freshly, then we should see it as something that is a little bit abnormal.
We often don't do that.
But what we need to do is see, why is nakedness a theme in chapters two and three?
It causes us to lean in.
Well, in chapter two, when everything was good, there was no prom at all, no sin.
Head into the world, what we know is the husband and the wife.
They were naked, they were under shame.
For some of you, that's your favorite verse in the Bible, but it's not supposed to be your favorite verse in the Bible for the reason that you're thinking it's your favorite verse in the Bible.
It's in fact, a favorite verse in the Bible because what it's expressing is that there was no shame between them.
They had nothing to hide.
They were totally safe.
They could be transparent with one another.
They had vulnerability in relationship to each other.
Does this sound amazing?
Having safety in a relationship.
That's what chapter two talks about.
And yet when you get to chapter three, that word naked, it pops up three more times and yet every time it does, their relationship to shame has changed.
Where they didn't have anything to hide from.
Now they have good reason to hide where they had nothing to be ashamed of.
Now they feel a deep sense of shame where they once were totally vulnerable.
Now they're closed off and concealed.
They don't want to be totally exposed to the other.
Why?
Why does that happen to them?
Why the massive change?
You want to know why?
They looked at that stupid fruit for too long.
They entertained temptation.
That's what we see.
It says that Eve, she doesn't just take the fruit.
It says that she notices the fruit.
We're gonna talk about what she notices, but here's why it's significant for us to understand.
Sin is never a flip of a switch.
It's always a slide into depravity.
Like I was joking with my team.
Nobody goes and serves with a local food bank.
And the next thing you know, hops in the car and starts trolling everybody on the internet.
That doesn't happen.
Why?
Because that would just be kind of a misappropriation of priority.
It would feel like, man, you're just a completely, it would be a false, it would be an absolute division between your character in one place and your character.
And another, we don't do that.
What instead happens is we slide into sin.
James 1, 14, 15 says, but each person is tempted when he's lured.
enticed by his own desire.
Then desire, when it's conceived, it gives birth to sin.
And sin, when it's fully grown, it brings forth death.
I think that word, Lord, is so helpful because it just, it paints this picture of putting out bait to entice a Christian to do what a Christian should not do.
The image here is
is of throwing out a lure.
What's a lure do whenever it's appealing to the appetite of a fish?
It shines and it splashes and it swims.
That's what sin does to you.
and splashes and shines and it swims in such a way that it appeals to your carnality, your appetite, until you actually start to move towards it.
And yet, again, it's not a switch, it's a, it's a slide.
That's why a single scene from a show, an advertisement on TV can lead you to pull out your phone and kind of look up that girl, that guy on Instagram and then as you look at them, you know what, next thing you know, you're looking at stuff on the internet that might lead you to kind of someplace, scratch the edge a bit.
And then as you do that, what you realize is now you're looking at pornography or masturbating in the bedroom or bathroom.
You slid.
For others of you, it's going to be something different.
It's drinks with coworkers after a really long and stressful day.
And yet that was awesome.
And so you head home and you want to have a couple more.
And as you have those drinks, you end up deciding, you know what?
Like, I would love to just kind of forget this day.
And so you black out and drink yourself to sleep.
Others, it's not something, it's not something of substance like that.
It's something more internal.
It's managing self-perception.
It leads you to venting and validating with your friends, just so you can feel good about who you are, yet that venting and that validating, it leads you into gossiping about other people.
And as you gossip about those other people ultimately, it creates within you a deep, Harvard hate for someone that didn't do anything to deserve it.
Until the last you realized, it's not them, I hate it's myself.
Still some of you, you have this desperate need for control.
And so it leads you to obsess over your image and it causes you to control your diet until eventually an eating disorder comes out.
You see how that works?
Sin does not switch its slides.
It moves in.
That's what happens to Eve.
She notices it before she takes it.
It says that she saw it was good for food.
Meaning it was appetizing.
She's feeling kind of hungry.
Thought a girl's got to eat.
That'll do the trick.
It says that it was a delight to the eyes.
It caused her to linger a little bit longer.
It wasn't just appetizing.
It was attractive.
And it says that it was desired to make one wise, meaning it wasn't just appetizing.
It wasn't just attractive.
It was advantageous.
It could give to her what she wanted.
And she could not find elsewhere.
That's how sin works.
That's how it works.
But listen, sin never works.
Like I don't know what your personal advice is.
I don't know if it's lust, comfort, control, approval, power.
I don't know what your thing is.
And yet what I know is that it might be appetizing.
It might be attractive.
It might seem advantageous, but it's not good.
It is not of God.
Isaiah 5 tells us, woe to those who call evil good and good evil.
Who put darkness for light and light for darkness.
Who put bitter for sweet and sweet for bitter woe to those who are wise in their own eyes and shrewd in their own sight.
Friends, listen, if you want to kill your sin, you must stop justifying your sin.
And the way you kill sin at least the first step is you kill the temptation.
You do not wait for a moment of high temptation to figure out what you're going to do in the fight.
No one enters into combat sports and thinks to themselves, I'm just going to hop in the ring and do this thing out.
And you know what?
It might go my way.
They don't do that.
They train for months on end.
Why?
That way when they get in there and things start to get crazy and the chaos starts to circulate, they're able to hear from their corner.
Remember the game plan.
Remember the game.
Take him to the ground.
Do whatever suits your strength.
So some of you, you need to not wait until you're in the battlefield to get in the war room.
Like you need to spend some time and not go on a trip and stay in a hotel room all by yourself just so then your lust can creep up and it can take you out.
Don't do that.
Some of you, you need not wait until you go see your family for whatever holiday is on the horizon just then to get there and realize all your old friends want you to come and hang out with them and all the hurts and habits from your past, they're now in your present.
You don't need to wait for that either.
Some of you, you're so stressed out and you're so anxious.
And so instead of trying to control your life and produce whatever outcomes you want, you just need to choose instead.
You know what?
I'm actually gonna invite some friends whenever I know stress is coming, that way they can pray for me and I can feel strongly supported.
You need to start planning for moments of high temptation and not falling prey to them.
Does that make sense?
Goodness gracious.
Sin is never justifiable.
This is why it's in me so bad for you to get this.
It's never justifiable.
It's always condemnable.
The wages of sin is what?
Life, no, death.
That's why it cost Christ his own life.
He had to give up himself for those that would not give up themselves.
And yet, he did so willingly.
And here's the crazy thing about it.
There's nothing justifiable about us that would ever beg him to come in.
We're not appetizing.
There's nothing good about us.
He can't see us and think, man, you know what?
I do want to come closer to them.
There's nothing good about us that would ever beg him to come close.
There's nothing attractive about us.
There's no beauty that would garner his attention.
And yet he comes.
Anyways, we have no advantage to offer him.
None.
He doesn't need us.
So why does he do this?
Why then does he not only come, why then does he take on our condemnation?
Because he wants us.
Why, Kylan?
I don't know why.
Because God chooses for that to be the case.
How great is love of God of this?
That Christ, he gave himself up while we were yet sinners.
Fourth thing, and bear with me, but we're going to finish this.
Verse eight, and they heard the sound of the Lord God walking in the garden in the cool of the day and the man and his wife, they hid themselves from the presence of the Lord God among the trees of the garden.
But the Lord God, he called to the man and he said to him, where are you?
And he said, I heard the sound of you in the garden.
I was afraid because I was naked and I hid myself.
He said, who told you that you were naked?
Have you eaten of the tree which I commanded you not to eat?
The man said, the woman whom you gave to be with me, she gave me fruit of the tree and I ate.
And in the Lord God said to the woman, what is this that you've done?
The woman said the serpent deceived me and I ate.
If you want to know why things keep going wrong, you need to know the fourth thing.
The fourth thing is things go wrong when we stop taking responsibility.
Things go wrong when we stop taking responsibility because that is absolutely what's happening here.
Adam, Eve, they just start blame shifting.
Adam goes first.
He blames God.
It's the woman you gave me.
I didn't pick her.
He blames Eve.
She brought me the fruit.
It's Eve's turn.
It wasn't my fault.
The serpent deceived me.
Everybody is blaming somebody, but nobody is taking responsibility, which we don't do that, do we?
It's funny.
I was visiting with a friend earlier today and he's like, you know, the number of conversations I'm having with people where I'm having to convince them of their sin,
is just crazy to me.
And you know what resonated as I heard him talking about that?
Repentance does not come from a convincing of man.
It comes from a conviction from God.
And so if someone's having to convince you, hey, you shouldn't treat people like that, hey, you shouldn't speak to people like that.
Hey, the things that you're doing with your boyfriend, girlfriend, don't really need to stop that.
That's not God honoring at all.
If someone's having to convince you of the things, the issue is not with them, it is with you.
And more than likely, if they've come to convince you, the spirit has been knocking and you've not been listening because conviction comes before anybody tries to convince.
So what's God do?
When all the blame shifting starts happening, when no one's willing to actually own their sin, they're just willing to acknowledge it, what happens in this moment?
Well, contrary to popular belief, he doesn't show up with a ruler in hand.
Growing up,
My mom, she had a paint switch and labeled on it was Kylan's attitude adjuster.
God does not do that for Adam.
Adam does not have an attitude adjuster.
God doesn't show up.
He doesn't condemn him.
He doesn't rebuke him.
He does not in any way execute him.
He does nothing that we often think God has come to do.
Instead, what does he do?
He just shows up for their daily walk.
And yet, where Adam and Eve.
They're hiding.
Why are they hiding?
Hear me on this.
This is really important.
They are hiding because for the righteous, the presence of God is delightful.
But for the wicked, the presence of God is dreadful.
They are filled with a fear.
They know they are wicked.
They are not as they should be.
They have been disobedient.
And as a result, they are to be despised above all men.
And yet God
He didn't pull him out by the hair, found ya!
Guess what?
It's time to take your look and let that's not what he does.
I love it.
He just starts asking questions.
Why does he ask questions?
Is it because he's not omniscient and he doesn't know what they did, he doesn't know what happened, he doesn't know what he's supposed to do?
No, God is all knowing.
He knows exactly what to do in this moment.
No, he does what parents do whenever they catch their kid doing something they shouldn't do.
sees they're guilty and then just ask them, hey, what happened?
He's trying to maintain relationship.
Do you see it?
God does not show up in a way where he ignores what's happened, but he does not show up in a way where he ignores what's happening to them.
That's big.
He does see the source of their shame, but he also sees the effect of it.
And so he takes care of his kids first.
He starts asking them questions.
Some of the questions I think he may be asking you tonight.
He asks them, hey, where are you?
Where are you?
He wants them to know that even, even when they're lost, he will still seek them in their hiding.
He asks them, who told you?
He wants them to know that even when you're misled, he'll speak to them what's true.
And he asks, what have you done?
Because he wants them to know that even when they're guilty, he'll still save them from their sin.
Don't you see, this is big, this is what Genesis 3 is about.
God's fundamental response to human failure, to your failure, is not condemnation.
It is compassion.
And I wholeheartedly believe, which is why I'm taking the time to
get it out of me and give it over to you that he is asking some of you the same questions tonight.
That he's looking at you and he's asking, where are you?
Where are you?
You're not where you're supposed to be.
We're supposed to walk.
We're supposed to be with one another.
We're supposed to be in relationship.
Where are you?
You're not where you're supposed to be.
But who told you that?
Why are you listening to those lies?
I didn't tell you that.
I've told you what's true.
I've declared to you that your mind, your mind, son, your mind, daughter, you're safe, you're secure, you're sealed forever in Christ Jesus, by way of the Spirit, into eternal life.
I don't want you just now.
I want you always.
Please ask him, what have you done?
What have you done?
That I cannot clean, that I cannot fix, that I cannot solve.
He's asking you tonight.
Where are you?
Who told you?
What have you done?
Because I, I can be right when you have been wrong.
You may not take responsibility, but I can take responsibility for you.
Last story, just last week, as I'm sure many of you did, and so too did people from all over the globe.
I sat down to watch the opening ceremony of the Olympics.
the event was amazing and towards the end of the time they do what is ceremonially true of every opening ceremony at the Olympics.
They bring in the Olympic torch.
I don't know if you know this about the Olympic torch, but the Olympic torch is riddled with symbolism.
It is so very significant because that torch is not lit by just
Any regular old flame, no one just struck a matcher, you know, pulled out the flame throw and decided to light the Olympic torch.
Instead, it is lit with a different fire.
It is lit with a fire from another world.
It is lit with the fire from the sun.
And that fire is carried from Olympia, Greece, every single game.
And it travels miles, thousands of miles to reach its ultimate destination.
And so as I saw them bringing the torch in, I was thinking about this moment that I was going to have with you.
And I couldn't help but wonder, what happens if something goes wrong?
It travels that far.
Surely it's been extinguished.
Surely it's been quenched.
Surely it's burned out at some point.
What happens in that event?
You want to know what happens?
There is a second flame.
There is a substitute that stands in the gap that burns where the first failed to burn brightest.
Friends, we have a second flame.
We have the second atom.
We have gone wrong, but he has stood in the gap.
He has taken our place.
He is from another world, but he has stepped into yours that you might know him
that you might trust Him, that you might believe in Him, and you might be saved by Him.
Do you know this compassionate, not condemning King, if you don't?
He's asking, where are you?
Because I'm here.
Let me pray that you would take the invitation.
God, I thank you for tonight.
And thank you, God, for just the power of your word, the sufficiency of it.
I'm grateful, God, that Lord, you've produced and me producing us, just this posture of heart that God says, we're not playing games anymore.
The world is filled with distraction and division.
This will not be a place like that.
We will not be distracted.
We will not be divided.
God, no, we will be devoted.
We will be united.
And yet, God, as we claim that we know, there is only one name that unites.
There is only one name that saves and it's yours.
It's Jesus.
O God, I pray, as we set at the beginning, in an evening that matters, won't you prove it to us?
Won't you pierce the heart that is within?
Pull it out and hold it forever.
Christ, we thank you that you lived the life we couldn't, that you died, the death we deserve, and you rose forth, and you have made eternal life available to all people if they would place their faith in you.
We sing to you now.
Oh God, do we sing?
It's in Christ's name.
Amen.